Herr Oberarzt, ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen und ich würde gerne über sie berichten.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja bitte.
Danke schön.
Frau Mathilde Altenstuhn ist 58 Jahre alt, 1 Meter, 68 groß und 760 Kilogramm schwer.
Frau Altenstuhn starte sich heute bei uns wegen seit 3 bis 4 Wochen bestehender Fatigue sowie
Cephalgie vor.
Der Patienten zufolge seien die Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten und mit der Zeit schlimmer
geworden.
Die Schmerzen seien dumpf und würden in den Nacken ausstrahlen.
Der Patient berichtete über trockene Mund, Konzentrationsstörungen, nächtliche Hyperhidrosen,
Insomnolenz und Schnarchen.
Die Fragen nach Tussis, Dyspne, Angina Pectoris, Tachikardi, Hyperthonsillemi wurden
bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die Folgenden bekannt.
Inapetenz, Insomnie in Form von Durchschlafstörungen und Nukturi 2 bis 3 Mal in der Nacht.
Sie sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft und sie besuche ihren Frauenarzt
regelmäßig alle 3 Monate.
Ihre letzte Monatsblutung war vor 8 Jahren.
An Vorerkrankungen nannte sie seit 4 Jahren bestehenden Diabetes mellitus, seit 2 Jahren
bestehende arterielle Hypertonie, vor 4 Jahren diagnostizierte rechtsseitige Fußfraktur
beim Fußballspiel und vor 2 Jahren diagnostizierte linksseitige Unterarmfraktur beim
Fahrradunfall.
Die Patienten nehmen Metformin 500 mg morgens und abends ein und die Patienten nehmen
ein Medikament gegen arterielle Hypertonie.
Der Name von Medikament sollte geklärt werden.
Die Frakturen wurden mit Gips behandelt und die Patienten haben einen Verbrannt
an rechten Oberarm gelitten, der konservativ behandelt worden sei.
Sie haben Allergie, Kreuzallergie gegen Tomaten und Birken, die sich durch Exzellen
am Arm und Bein äußern, manchmal am ganzen Körper.
Sie sei Raucherin und sie rauche 10 Zigaretten täglich seit 2 Jahren.
Sie trinke ein Glas Wein gelegentlich und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Familienanamnese gab sie an, dass die Mutter 84 Jahre alt sei und leide an
die Tochter.
Sie ist eine Tochter mit einer hohen Arthrose und der Vater sei gesund.
Sie sei ein Einzelkind verheiratet und habe 3 gesunde Kinder und sie wohne mit
ihrer Familie zusammen.
Sie sei Tierpflegerin von Beruf.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine obstruktive Schlafapnesyndrom aus, da die
Patienten typische Symptome dafür aufweisen.
Die Patienten leiden unter chronischer Fatigue, Cephalgie, Schnarchen, diese
Symptome und Konzentrationsstörungen und Insomnolenz tagsüber.
Diese Symptome sprechen für eine obstruktive Schlafapnesyndrom.
Als die Phranzei Diagnosen kommen Migräne, Depression, Gehirntumor in Betracht.
Um meine Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen, würde ich zunächst bei der Patienten
die Vitalparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung und eine neurologische
Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der neurologischen Untersuchung achte ich darauf, ob die Störungen der Motorik,
Sensorik und andere Veränderungen volllegen.
Ich würde darauf achten, ob die Patienten Hautfarbeveränderungen haben.
Zusätzlich ist eine Laboruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnose zu
gewährleisten. Dabei würde ich Brutbild, CAP, BSG, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte,
Elektrolyten bestimmen lassen.
Danach würde ich eine CT des Schädels durchführen, um die möglichen
Pathologien auszuschließen, wie zum Beispiel Gehirntumor.
Danach würde ich eine EEG durchführen, um die wirkliche Pathologie genau zu beurteilen.
Darüber hinaus würde ich eine Polysomnographie durchführen, um die Obstruktivschlafapnessyndrom
genau zu bestätigen. Sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich
die Patienten stationär aufnehmen und ich würde ein HNO-Konzil anfordern, um die
Therapie der Patienten zu optimieren. Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden
sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren, Herr Oberarzt.
Herr Kollegen, Sie haben gesagt, ich würde in diesem Fall eine CT des Schädels
durchführen. Können Sie uns die CT des Schädels aufklären?
Ja, gerne. Ich werde Sie über CT des Schädels aufklären.
Computer-Tomography gehört zu den bildgebenden Verfahren.
Diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die Verletzungen, Entzündungen, Blutungen, Tumore und andere
Veränderungen genau zu erkennen. Diese Untersuchung benötigt nur noch eine geringe
Strahlenbelastung und ist völlig schmerzfrei. Der Patient soll etwa 30 Minuten in eine
CT-Röhre ruhig liegen und wenn der Patient eine Platzangst hat, können wir dem Patienten
eine Beruhigungsmittel geben. Diese Untersuchung hat keine Komplikationen, aber es gibt einige
Kontraindikationen, wie zum Beispiel Schwangerschaft oder Kontrastmittelallergie. Manchmal
sollen wir dem Patienten eine Kontrastmittel geben, um die innere Organe sichtbar zu machen.
Und es gibt keine Einschränkungen nach der Untersuchung und der Patient kann den Alltag
wie gewohnt fortsetzen. Okay, Herr Kollegen, wie würden Sie Migräne
in diesem Fall ausschließen? Ja, die Patientin leidet unter einem Kopfschmerzen,
die besonders morgens auftreten. Also normalerweise warten wir eine Kopfschmerzen
bei der Migraine nur an einer Seite vom Kopf und normalerweise warten wir eine Aura bevor
ein Anfall und nach der Migranten-Attacke warten wir auf Schleppigkeit oder Müdigkeit.
Diese Schmerzen bei dieser Patientin sind im Stil gelokalisiert und nicht so stark,
aber leider habe ich über Schmerzintensität und die Details nicht gefragt. Nach dem
Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch werde ich diese Frage wieder stellen, Herr Oberarzt.
Was würde in diesem Fall Obststruktur Schlafapne verursachen?
Normalerweise ist die Übergewicht die erste Ursache bei der Erwachsenen, aber die
Patientin ist nicht übergewicht, sie ist Raucherin. Also Rauchen ist ein Risikofaktor
bei dieser Situation, also ich meine Obststruktur Schlafapnesyndrom und sie schnarchen beim
Schlafen und wahrscheinlich hat sie Atemstillstand beim Schlafen, deswegen würde ich eine
Polysomnographie durchführen, um diese Probleme genau festzustellen. Nach der Behandlung,
was würden Sie diesen Patienten empfehlen? Ja, Lebensstillveränderung ist bei diesen
Patienten sehr wichtig, also Rauchen aufzuhören ist wichtig und eine körperliche Untersuchung
und wenn es eine Mandelvergrößerung oder Uhula-Hypertrophy oder September-Deviation
gibt, können wir der Patienten eine Operation empfehlen und Schlafpositionveränderung
ist auch sehr wichtig beim Schlafen und als Therapiemöglichkeiten würde ich der
Patienten eine SPAP, also Schlafmaske empfehlen, das ist die erste Wahl bei diesen Patienten.
Würden Sie in diesem Fall Elektroencephalographie durchführen? Ja, Elektroencephalographie würde
ich durchführen, um die elektrische Aktivität des Gehirns genau zu beurteilen, die die
Patientin hat, Cephalgie und Schlafstörungen, deswegen würde ich eine EEG durchführen.
Wie können wir Elektroencephalographie durchführen? Können Sie uns so aufklären?
Ja gerne, ich werde Sie über EEG aufklären. Elektroencephalographie ist eine Untersuchung,
mit der wir die elektrische Aktivität des Gehirns aufzeichnen können, dazu mehrere
Elektroden am Kopf befestigt und diese Elektroden messen die elektrische Aktivität des Gehirns
und zeigen sie als Kurve auf einem Monitor und diese Untersuchung hilft uns, die epileptische
Anfälle oder andere Gehirnkrankheiten genau zu erkennen. Diese Untersuchung dauert ca.
20 Minuten, dafür benötigt der Patient keine spezielle Vorbereitung, es gibt keine
Komplikationen oder Kontraindikationen bei dieser Untersuchung und nach der Untersuchung
kann der Patient den Alltag wie gewohnt fortsetzen.
In diesem Fall ist es möglich, Kraftanfall?
Die Patienten leiden keine chronischen oder kringenden Anfälle, aber es gibt viele verschiedene
epileptische Anfälle, auf jeden Fall sollen wir eine EEG durchführen, um die möglichen
Pathologien zu beurteilen. Wie gesagt, es gibt keine Befunde für eine epileptische Anfälle,
Herr Oberhans.
Ich habe alle Fragen gestellt, gehen Sie auf unser Infodesk und nehmen Sie Ihre Zertifizierung.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberhans, Sie sind sehr nett, Sie haben heute weniger Fragen gestellt,
ich bedanke mich. Nur zwei Minuten.